>> Laura: LET'S BE HONEST,
TRUMP IS THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO
CONFRONT CHINA, WHICH IS
INCREASINGLY WEALTHY,
INCREASINGLY AGGRESSIVE, LARGEST
STANDING ARMY IN THE WORLD, NO
ONE ELSE HAS DONE IT LIKE HIM.
NOW THERE MAY BE A MAJOR FIGHT
BREWING WITH MEXICO OVER TRADE,
THE WALL, WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR
IT?
MY NEXT GUEST IS AT THE CENTER
OF IT ALL.
HE MIGHT NOT BE A HOUSEHOLD NAME
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WANT TO
MISS ANY OF THIS.
HE JOINS US EXCLUSIVELY.
THANKS FOR BEING BACK WITH US.
WE READ THAT NOW ON THIS ISSUE
OF NAFTA RENEGOTIATION, ALL
THESE GREAT NEW DEALS ARE GOING
TO START, THERE HAS BEEN A SNAG
IN THE NEGOTIATIONS AND IT WAS
REPORTED THAT THERE WAS A CALL
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
MEXICAN PRESIDENT PENA NIETO AND
IT ENDED IN SOME KIND OF TESTING
MANNER.
I GUESS THE HOLDUP WAS OVER WHO
WAS GOING TO FUND THE WALL.
MY RADIO LISTENERS CHIMED IN ON
THIS TOPIC ABOUT WHETHER IT
MATTERS IF MEXICO PAYS OR IF
IT'S AN INDIRECT PAYMENT, LET'S
LISTEN.
>>
>> Laura: MR. AMBASSADOR, IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE HARD-CORE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS CARE ABOUT THE
WALL SO WHY SHOULD THAT BE A
SNAG HERE?
IT SEEMS LIKE HE PLAYED THIS
REALLY SMARTLY AS A NEGOTIATING
MATTER.
>> THE WALL IS OUT OF MY LANE, I
STAY IN MY LANE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A WALL, BEYOND
THAT, I STAY IN MY LANE.
MY LANE IS ABOUT TRYING TO GET
NEW DEALS.
IT'S TRYING TO REVERSE A VERY
BAD TREND THAT WE HAVE HAD FOR A
LONG TIME IN THE TRADE AREA.
THE PRESIDENT RAN ON THIS, HE
FEELS STRONGLY ABOUT IT WHEN I
TALK TO HIM, ITS WORKERS,
RANCHERS, FARMERS, THAT'S IT.
IT'S WAGES AND ITS JOBS.
IF WE RENEGOTIATE THAT DEAL, IF
WE GET A GOOD DEAL WITH MEXICO
AND CANADA IF POSSIBLE WE ARE
GOING TO FIND MORE JOBS.
>> Laura: THE BIGGEST HOLDUP
SEEMS TO BE ABOUT AUTO
MANUFACTURING AND THAT'S WITH A
LION'S SHARE WITH OUR TRADE
DEFICIT OF MEXICO IS.
I WAS SHOCKED TO READ TODAY THAT
77% OF MEXICAN MANUFACTURED
VEHICLES THAT WERE EXPORTED CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS BECAUSE THERE IS NO
TARIFF ON THOSE BECAUSE OF NAFTA
TARIFF ON THOSE BECAUSE OF NAFT
NAFTA.
WHAT WILL A POTENTIAL DEAL LOOK
LIKE REGARDING THAT TYPE OF
IMBALANCE?
>> THE BIGGEST PART OF THE
PROBLEM BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES FOR THE TRADE POINT OF
VIEW IS MEXICO HAS AN INDUSTRIAL
POLICY WHICH IS A SMART ONE.
IT'S DESIGNED TO GET AUTO
COMPANIES TO MOVE TO MEXICO AND
SHIPPED TO THE U.S.
YOU SAY 70 OF 7% FOR SOME
COMPANIES IT'S EVEN HIGHER.
A LOT OF THESE ARE COMPANIES
WITH VERY LITTLE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE MADE IN AMERICA.
LOW U.S. CONTENT.
THE KIND OF THING WE ARE LOOKING
AT IS TO HAVE A BETTER BALANCE,
HIGHER REGIONAL CONTENT BUT
HIGHER U.S. CONTENT AND TO
REORGANIZE THE WAY WE KEEP TRACK
OF WHICH IS WHICH.
THE PRESIDENT'S OBJECTIVE IS WE
HAVE TO GET MORE JOBS BACK TO
AMERICA, WE HAVE TO REDUCE THE
DEFICIT.
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY PUT
PRESSURE ON WAGES.
>> Laura: GLOBAL TRADE IS A
BIG PUBLICATION, CRITICS WILL
SAY ADVANCED ECONOMIES HAVE BEEN
STEADILY REDUCING THE CHAIR OF
JOBS IN MANUFACTURING AND THAT
IS ACCOUNTING FOR A LOT OF THE
JOB LOSSES IN THE UNITED STATES.
YOU CAN NAIL SOME OF THEM TO
NAFTA BUT MOST OF THAT IS
BECAUSE IMPROVING AND
PRODUCTIVITY, TECHNOLOGY
CHANGING, WE ARE STEADILY MOVING
AWAY FROM THOSE TYPES OF
MANUFACTURING JOBS, WHAT DO YOU
SAY TO THAT?
>> THE GREATEST ECONOMIES IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW, UNITED STATES,
CHINA, GERMANY, JAPAN.
WHO SAID IT GERMANY AND JAPAN
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MANUFACTURING?
AS A PERCENTAGE IT'S SHRINKING
PERHAPS.
BUT THOSE ARE STILL GREAT JOBS,
VERY IMPORTANT JOBS AND THEY
SPIN OFF WEALTH TO THOUSANDS,
MILLIONS OF OTHER PEOPLE -- TO
ME IT'S COMPLETE NONSENSE TO SAY
WE DON'T NEED MANUFACTURING.
>> Laura: IF WE HAVE A
$70 BILLION TRADE DEFICIT WITH
MEXICO, WE HAVE EIGHT TIMES THAT
WITH CHINA.
LAST YEAR WAS THE BIGGEST TRADE
DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE EVER HAD.
NOW YOU HAVE TO DECIDE BY APRIL
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO
WITH CHINESE ALUMINUM IMPORTS,
UNDER MARKET PRICED GOODS AND
THEY ARE NOW SAYING WE COULD
RETALIATE ON YOUR AGRICULTURE,
THERE'S A TRADE WAR, TRUMP IS
GOING TO START A TRADE WAR, IT'S
GOING TO BE A NIGHTMARE.
AND YOU SAY?
>> IT'S NONSENSE.
WE HAVE A VERY IMBALANCED
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
ONCE AGAIN IT'S NOT BASED ON
BASIC ECONOMICS, IT'S BASED ON
INDUSTRIAL POLICY.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT HAS A
CENTRALLY DRIVEN KIND OF ECONOMY
CENTRALLY DRIVEN KIND OF ECONOM
ECONOMY.
THEY TAKE TECHNOLOGY, THEY
SUBSIDIZE, THAT USE ACCESS TO
MARKETS AND CREATE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF WEALTH AND IMBALANCE
WITH THE UNITED STATES NOT BASED
ON ECONOMICS.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T KNOW THE
NUANCE OF POLICY.
HE WILL GET ON THE PHONE WITH
SOMEONE AND BLOW UP
NEGOTIATIONS -- HE DOESN'T
FOLLOW THE NITTY-GRITTY OF
THINGS LIKE TRADE OR MILITARY
POLICY.
YOU ARE IN ALL THESE MEETINGS
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON A WEEKLY
BASIS, I KNOW YOU CAN'T REVIEW
WHAT HE SAYS BUT YOU CAN TELL
US -- DOES HE GET THESE CONCEPTS
US -- DOES HE GET THESE CONCEPT
CONCEPTS?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WHEN HE WAS
35 YEARS OLD AND FOLLOW IT TO
WHAT HE'S SAYING RIGHT NOW, IT'S
THE SAME THING.
HE UNDERSTANDS THE ISSUES.
WHEN I AM IN THESE MEETINGS IT
IS VERY STRONG GIVE-AND-TAKE
FROM A VARIETY OF PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS BEYOND ENGAGED,
HE CARES ABOUT JOBS AND WAGES,
POLITICS NEVER COMES UP.
WHEN HE'S NOT THINKING ABOUT
JOBS AND WAGES ITS WAGES AND
JOBS.
>> Laura: I APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON AND SPENDING SOME
TIME.
>> THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE VERY FEW
PEOPLE THAT IS ACTUALLY PUSHING
IT AND PART OF THE REASON IS
IT'S COMPLICATED BUT IT IS